okay I am a unique pleasure to introduce
the afternoon session on transportation
sharing systems
I guess this first speaker is Dana
choice whoo okay thanks Ava so indeed
I'm going to talk about bike sharing
systems and their operation is a case
study and the kinds of real-time
decision making and decision making more
generally so many of you have seen a
bike sharing system in action you only
need to walk out to Bancroft
to to see it firsthand but in case you
haven't hear you know bike sharing 101
so a bike sharing system first of all
consists of a map of stations at least
as the doc version in North America most
prevalent a station consists of a set of
docks which are then filled with bikes
hopefully not completely filled with
bikes and a user is allowed to pick up a
bike at any station and rented it
together typically a subscriber has a
fab like this you stick it into the dock
it releases a bike and then you can
return the bike at any station in the
system so your phone app will have a
display that looks something like this
this is around NYU in New York City each
of those little thought bubbles
corresponds to a station the level of
the dark blue in the the bubble reflects
the fraction of docks at that station
that are currently filled with bikes so
you can see here it's things are a
little low on bikes
here we're completely out of Docs so so
there's this two-sided problem of both
needing availability for both bikes and
docks at any any given place Gupta
Cornell has been involved in bike
sharing sin since the initiation of city
bike in May 2013 and I guess I hurried
through the title slide I should should
emphasize that that this is really the
work of two of my PhD students Oh a
nominee now an uber and Daniel Freund
and collaborative with my colleague in O
R at Cornell Stein Henderson and many
many students that have participated in
different projects along the way so to
give you a sense of just let's focus on
New York cities and city bike to give
you some order of magnitude in a good
weather month this year in 2017 there
were nearly two million rides in New
York City that were taken in part of the
system Paris which perhaps has a
notoriety for for being the first large
very large system is is still a bit
bigger at 3 million rides but the
trajectory is increasing there were like
10 million rides in city bike in 2015 14
million rides in 2016 I don't know the
figures yet for 2017 but it's going to
be close to 20 million maybe even over
20 million all totaled currently there
are roughly 12,000 bikes in the system
and more than 500 stations and there
just is continual ongoing expansion of
the system itself well we've got an
involved we earned our street cred
actually by helping them a route repair
man for battery replacements in in their
first months of first weeks really days
and weeks of crisis level but the main
focus of our interaction has been what
commonly goes under the name of
rebalancing and I'll talk much more
about that give you a sense of North
American statistics this is gives you
of the the steady rate of increase not
just in New York but but really
throughout I should point out that for
several these Capital Bikeshare divvy
and hub way they are all under the same
conglomerate umbrella company motivate
and so many of the things that I
although I'm focusing on on Citi bike
many of the pieces of analytical tools
that we've done for New York have been
exported to the other systems so I
already mentioned the word imbalance
what do I mean by imbalance the question
is the issue is that the asymmetry of
demand of where bikes of people tend to
commute from and the intensity of the
commute patterns means that some
stations may be without any docks free
and some may be without bikes free and
that of course leads to upset customers
so the first thing I want to do is just
give you a feel for the kind of data
that we have as part of the system and
and in some sense that will then lead to
how we actually make decisions so the
first thing I want to do is show you a
day in the life of New York City this is
actually a bit old data by now it's
maybe June of 2016 this I can tell from
the pattern of stations each of these
circles represents a station in in New
York and as you watch the the day evolve
the radius of the city is going to be
your indication of the intensity of the
net flow of bikes the color is going to
indicate whether that net flow is in or
out blue being more more flow in red
being more flow out at the top you're
going to see you have a clock which will
start at midnight and we'll watch what
happens throughout the day okay so get
this started
it's the middle of the night but you
know this is the city that never sleeps
so so you see some percolation of
activity of some but it's really low
level now it's starting to be dawn and
the first thing you'll see is the
traffic hubs the Port Authority
and in Penn Station wake up with people
leaving it and they're going down to the
Penn Station
now the East Village is waking up and
and and now you're going traffic into
Midtown and and now it's the rush hours
calm down things are a little bit
quieter there's maybe a little pickup
around noon
for additional traffic and now you're
going to see the reverse more or less
for the river the evening commute you're
going to see outgoing traffic from the
financial district outgoing traffic from
Midtown into the transit hubs back into
the residential neighborhood of the East
Village the evening rush hour is a bit
longer than the afternoon in the morning
one lingering just a bit further and
little by little we fade back to the way
we started at midnight okay so that
gives you a sense there's there's
there's there's a definite sense in
which the rush hours are the dominant
piece it's not by any means the the you
know it's not everything there is this
asymmetry of directionality between the
the two rush hours it's not perfectly
symmetric and therein lies a lot of the
challenges and that we have a pretty
quiet period overnight where hopefully
we can take advantage of that to do some
planning now one of the nice things
about a system like this is that it sort
of records its own state so here we have
a plot so this is one day in the life of
a station at Atlantic and Fort Greene in
Brooklyn the y-axis is the number of
bikes in that station and the x-axis
gives us the time from 6:00 a.m. to
midnight oh and and we sort of see the
fill level and this is a very
uninteresting station you might notice
that here we have an outage we're at
that point there are are no bikes but
but by and large it's a pretty
uneventful day and now of course you
might say what was this typical I mean
here are actually three
in the cellar in the same week we we see
then yeah this one was kind of
unfortunate in that we maybe started the
fill with too few bikes at 6:00 a.m. and
as a result we went out but but but by
and large this isn't a big deal okay and
this is a boring station this is at
least at this point in the life of the
system by now actually I think this is a
significantly more active station oh but
but put that in contrast with the same
week here's a Oh actually one more thing
I wanted to point out this green line
across the top is the capacity of that
station this is how many docks there
actually were this they are at this
station so somewhere in excess of 60 so
we're you know great and no number of
docks that that just simply were never
used and and seemed likely to never be
used given the the state of traffic
here's actually a somewhat smaller
station it's under 40 docks located in
the heart of Midtown so 52nd and Fifth
Avenue and and you seem much more wild
oscillations in in the rate of incoming
traffic they're not not terribly
surprising as we saw in the the the
day-in-the-life in the morning we have
large incoming flow net flows and the
afternoon we have large outgoing net
flows but you might wonder well what's a
spike like this this is a rebalancing
truck this is a truck arriving with a
large number of bikes I guess about 30
so it's probably it's a box truck and
then we see so it just it's the sucked
out of the system and and would get used
up good and indeed you see some of the
effects of rebalancing throughout the
day okay so and and and one other sort
of from 30,000 feet perspective that
while you know the the profiles of these
days are similar stochasticity means at
any given point in time you know every
day is a little bit different but but
sort of maybe not so quite so if you
look at Balaji's plots from taxi traffic
there is the in part due to the
unpredictability of rebalancing probably
more than anything else the the
signature from day to day is it has a
bit more variability in it yes yes oh
there are ways in which you don't really
know everything about the system if you
look at this plot then and you look at
what's happening up here you can see
that something isn't quite right oh you
have this this sort of random walk of
getting to some level and then losing a
bike and getting some level losing bike
and you never hit the capacity all right
you have a broken doc oh so so so so so
so you know inferring what's going on
you know it takes a little bit of
reading between the lines yes no this is
this is just raw data so so so we we
have really and I'll talk about this
momentarily we know about the
transactions that occurred we don't know
about the transactions that didn't occur
because there wasn't supply and and and
this is the effect that we you know
really want to do something to figure
out to make sure that we have an
appreciation for what the data is
telling us no it's definitely not
one-to-one that there so it's roughly
two to one I mean one of the things that
I wish shocked by when I when I first
interacted with the company they said
well at that point they were at a
different state there were 12,000 docs
in 6000 bikes and they were very proud
of it was 12,000 bikes in success and
dachshund they said well you know our
goal is to start every rush hour with
every station half full
and I thought I don't think that's
really there let lets let's talk in a
couple weeks which indeed we did and
then then life changed and indeed you
all with guilt you'll you'll hear much
more about us
right near the station as they were to
certify checking if a neighboring
station like you get thrown so this is
the point I almost made a middle of
apologies talking and this is the chief
data science for the MTA in Boston sort
of highlighted this in my mind a lot of
these public private entities made the
mistake I mean they're sort of
legislated to do this of making all
their data public so what has happened
then is that the app support for you
know where's the bus or any of these
things has a number of private apps that
are that are living off of the public
feeds and so and in particular and I'll
be brutally honest these the city bike
I've app was really bad initially none
of the almost all of the users quickly
migrated to other feeds for what the
data was and so they don't even know
it's like uber knows when an uber user
wants to you know use a car they know
when they opened and they didn't and
what that mean we I mean it is true that
their their data systems don't actually
track opens that don't correspond to to
rinse and it should but it's the do we
be missing a lot of that information as
well okay one of our yeah isn't so
definitely bright tone is set please
just fire away with questions yeah they
cost about the same so so a bite well
that a city bike bike order of magnitude
we're talking about a thousand dollars
and the electric me and so the way the
doc works is there's the physical piece
that's that that's just sitting there
permanently but but there's
electromagnet make
mechanism that that really just fires a
pin that locks the the the bike in place
within the thing and those are
interchangeable you've taken me and they
get repaired on a very steady basis and
they cost about a thousand dollars to
manufacture as well so so it's about the
same good one of the things that we took
as a starting point in when we we first
started being optimistic about what we
could do is that exactly around this
framing of wells starting each rush hour
in some state and trying to plan around
that that we thought that let's just
think about the planning period as being
a rush hour and then there's some lesser
amount of traffic that can allow some
amount of recovery between rush hours
and then certainly then there's the
overnight period which allows a better
and more complete umbria initialization
so one of the first things we we thought
about well for simplicity of modeling if
we're going to think about this in a
kind of traditional stochastic model
kind of way if let's let's a first cut
of sort of thinking about of our data
was we believed that it made sense to
the thing throughout the morning rush
hour
although there'll be some variation but
to think about for the intense run
morning rush hour to just think about
the rate of for each station the the
rate of rental is being relatively
constant and and the rate of returns is
being essentially constant and this
station shows you how wrong we can be
because if you look at what's happening
through the morning rush though the
weekend days are one thing but on the
work days you see already the the fill
level going straight up in the first
part of the rush hour and then going
smack down and the second half of the
rush hour so you have real turnarounds
with it now this is a particularly
extreme case it has to do with probably
being immediately next to Bellevue
Hospital and there may be a staff change
that that's it's really driving it's
also next to a daycare with drop-offs
and pickups of kids and and and and like
so there are a range of different
factors that might be driving this
behavior but certainly the sense that
you have to be sensitive that you have a
pretty narrow window in which things
sort of stay the same is is something
one should be sensitive to in terms of
the data coming back to the question the
earlier of this in this notion of
censoring data we we get to record the
trips that occur but we didn't record
the trips that we were missing so here's
a plot of one pretty intense station
really the biggest the moment at that at
this point in time the most intense
station and the system outside of Penn
Station each row in this plot
corresponds to one day in a month and we
have the time axis from midnight to
midnight going across the the x-axis and
for each 10-minute window I'm going to
color code from deep red meaning I'm out
of Doc's deep blue meaning I'm out of
out of bikes and sort of the greenish in
the middle as being things are basically
okay so we're sort of with warnings of
blue and warnings of red that I mean and
I mean of course the the first order bit
is there's much more of a problem in
being out of bikes than being out of
docks here but but notice that if I look
at a given 10 minutes slice in one part
of the day there are parts of yours no
no even for every part of ten minutes
slice there's some fraction of the days
for which life is basically okay and so
we can take advantage of the fact of
seeing what demand rates are for those
dates and in terms of the measurable
ones that we have and therefore just
sort of by renormalizing allow us to get
a better estimate of what the the latent
demand is now there there are more
serious issues in doing this and this is
I think one of the interesting data
analytic challenges that of course how a
station is perceived by individuals you
in that
neighborhood affects their willingness
to subscribe to become active users and
so that their there are other sort of
behavioral effects that are that are
also affecting in some sense latent
demand but but this at least gives us a
cut in terms of of users in the system
[Music]
so this is definitely a central question
and and and I'm gonna give away my
punchline later but but but the punch
line is the rebalancing capabilities is
Epsilon oh they're really at least as
and you can argue that maybe they're not
allocating sufficient resources but in
terms of the total resources that they
that they actually are from their
current business model willing to invest
in there they're doing very little
rebalancing overall but we'll talk about
exactly what modes of rebalancing and
exactly how this comes into
decision-making in running the system
okay so to give you a sense of the
effect of doing this sort of cross month
data cleaning if you will here are two
stations again a Midtown station where
we you know expect so here's the
question of on the top we have a demand
for rentals and here we have a demand
for returns so this is Midtown so we
know this we have a lot of incoming
traffic and that the effect of using the
pure data and the the sensor the the D
censored version in in the solid line so
so so it gives us some ability to
correct for for what we're missing
because at some point we don't have
demand because we don't have capacity so
again this is just in some sense of
proportionate rescaling by by taking
advantage that they were only measuring
demand when we actually conserve it
balaji also talked about the fact of
having simulation tools for thinking
about and playing with with with with
synthetic versions of the system is an
important tool in trying to understand
what's going on and as part of trying to
build a simulation model if you sort of
think about that system one thing that o
is is sort of key for for understanding
a one-element is well if i start at this
station and end at this station you know
how long is a typical ride so what you
see here is a log-log plot of the
distance between stations on the x-axis
and the length of the ride on the y-axis
and each point is one point is one ride
in a day of that and that's log base e
and durations are measured in seconds
and and and distances are measured in
kilometers and that's one day sort of
you know it's it all seems kind of
reasonable no no no big surprises there
but that's actually because the eye is
bad at such things this is if I put one
month worth of data all of a sudden you
sort of see kind of an interesting
horizontal line that's that's that's
that's that's visible here in terms of
intensity and you know we even took us
for a moment to think about that go
through what's what what is a correspond
to in terms of e to the 8 number of
seconds so the I mean they do I mean so
they're here's the punchline the the
subscription is based on when your
subscriber you have 45 3 minutes and
that horizontal line is the 45 minute
line so you sort of see independent of
the distance that people are people hang
on to their bikes more up to the point
that they get for free and then
when that expires then then they're much
more eager to get it back in okay yes
so exactly that this may be difficult to
see in this thin the slide just to give
you some sense of the contrast between
weekday usage and weekend usage these
are the top K and I don't remember
exactly the K maybe 25 pair two pair and
and most frequently used routes
superimposed on each other the main
takeaway message is leisure in Central
Park commercial activity in Midtown
right and you just really see
dramatically there in terms of how the
the patterns of usage get it differ
between the two generic differences okay
so so so again not very surprising but
but the data tells you what what what
you sort of expect okay okay so so
that's an overview of the data uh but
now let's talk about performance and
let's talk about those upset users and
how are we going to actually build a
model that allows us to sort of as I
think about the state of the system I
can ask questions like is the state good
in terms of what I expect in terms of
how things are performing and we're
going to then of course want to use this
for planning and no reiterating many of
the things I've already hit upon you
know the heavy is most of the trips are
by commuters concentrated 6:00 to 10:00
a.m. and Forte p.m. in some sense it's
natural to view a daily planning period
is 6:00 a.m. to 12:00 12:00 midnight and
and to think about restarting that and
we want some metric to say that how good
is our current state as we think about
the evolution of the day and the
objective that we're going to use as our
benchmark is what is good gradually
unified across the literature we call
the user dissatisfaction function is
that as I think about some stochastic
model of the underlying traffic
throughout the day it's the expected
number of total bike and docstoc outs of
outages as a user shows up in the
remainder of the planning period
so in some sense very much the number of
upset users that we expect ok what's the
natural model for the underlying setting
for for how to think about the traffic
we're going to think about a plus all
flow of of bikes that where we can back
in the rates from from our historical
data and each station we're going to
think of and this is Anita in Assumption
which you know has can be tested to some
extent by a back-end it's a simulation
model of we're going to think about
modeling stations using a continuous
time Markov chain that are independent
for different stations where the the
rates are going to be piecewise constant
and in particular we're gonna for every
30 minutes have a rental and return rate
for each station and again we're going
to then be interested in computing the
number of accepts upset people so again
you know I'm thinking about a station
it's it's in a state between being empty
and being full and the arrival is either
going to bump me up one state in terms
of one more bike or bump me down in
terms of one fewer and what I'm going to
essentially have is an underlying thing
is that as a function of the original
number of starting number of bikes or
the current number of bikes for the rest
of the planning period what's the
expected number of outages that I'm
going to see again we originally thought
with this doing this over a rush hour
but but but because of the data as we
saw it we're gonna be thinking about
this as sort of in a series of in this
case thirty-six half hour planning
periods as we go between between 6:00
a.m. and midnight and and we're going to
have the same model just just time
dependent and and and I won't go through
the mechanics but it's an easy recursion
to say that if I know how to do it for
constant possible rates I can can can do
this in a stochastic recursion for
throughout the t period day so what are
these curves look like so I now have a
cost function so again for this plot the
x-axis is the number of bikes at 6 a.m.
that I currently have and now I'm
thinking about the number of out of
stock events that happen at that station
over the rest of the day this is outside
the Port Authority so again you know
this is something where we start out the
day with a great surge of rentals
and we see that that really with a slope
of minus 1 every additional bike that I
have in my docks saves me an expected
outage there I want those but I want
that dock full at the Port Authority and
you know I have some hopeless amount of
outage amounts anyway even if I start
with that doubtful at 4200 is that that
station in Brooklyn is still a much more
benign kind of station it's there is you
know you want to have some number of
bikes initially
because then you'll actually have some
some outages if you start with too few
but beyond a certain amount going up to
that full capacity is is it's going to
potentially give you some dock outages
but but there's this large sweet spot in
terms of what the right number of bikes
that you would want to have in place and
essentially not never see an outage of
of either side Midtown is just the
reverse of the Port Authority you you
want it essentially empty oh and you
wanted empty and
for every bike you put in there and at
6:00 a.m. you gain an extra outage and
and and and all sorts of behavior is
visible throughout as you go across the
the suite of stations and of course this
really sort of says that for each
station there there's a you know 6 a.m.
target level of you know what's the
optimal number of bikes that that you
want to at that station at that time
which is as in a simulation if we could
introduce two tiers of service one word
reservation on one yeah yep so you can
call ahead the app stuff you can do this
probably is money for your bathtub well
I've thought about it and then they're
saying something like the scale for the
city bus if you're moving like
passengers and some of them want seats
with absolute you can even assign bus
combinations to change which seats the
site that's actually something with
cities I would even listen to just
because it's enough people yes indeed
you'll see it on a slide a tour tiendas
sort of things that that are interesting
and to come yep yep absolutely so so so
that was the snapshot at 6:00 a.m. so
now for these plots rather than thinking
about an absolute capacity
let me renormalize because I'm going to
be looking at each of these colors is a
different station so this is just the
fraction of of the docs that we want
full and as I think about optimizing
over the next to the end of the midnight
planning period for each of these times
what's the optimal bike allocation for
that
as in minimizing the outages and again
you sort of see to highest-level pieces
that of course the released village
which was residential in one of these
places where they're great outflows that
that we really want to keep things
stocked until people stop going and it
actually is much later than then I mean
the East Village is usually referred to
as a bike desert by 9:00 a.m. let alone
through the midnight that the models
would like us to keep it filled and the
financial district of course you you
know the point where you really need
them is is on the way home and that you
want it empty for arrivals but notice
that in some sense both sort of say that
that you want some residue that there's
some local amount of traffic that that
it's needed within the financial
district even in the wee hours of the
morning that that's that the models are
calling for is the coupling effect
between stations for this for this
metric that you're trying to so again
based on doing things that they don't
sort of have the separation the fact
that we're viewing them as independent
doesn't seem to be too bad it it's it is
that there is an effect but because of
course if Penn Station is out then then
places that normally receive bikes from
Penn Station are gonna see Adam you
nishan of a of incoming traffic and then
it's going to ripple so so there there
are natural effects to be thinking about
but but they are second and third order
one more plot on data so and it's nice
to focus on things like Midtown and Penn
Station where the asymmetries are clear
but in this plot so this is a scatter
plot each dot corresponds to one station
and we're looking at well what's what is
our user dissatisfaction say about the
fraction that should be filled at 7:00
a.m. versus what should be filled at
4:00 a.m. and and see there so I mean
the the upper left corner are those
things where you know you're
station where you really want to go out
and it's going to be empty there
this is Midtown or financial district
but you see that there's a diversity
across the the set of stations in terms
of that that asymmetry which is
predominant in terms of how the plaza is
not is not the whole story
oh so so okay so so so now we have a
metric to think about how to evaluate
performance we understand the data how
are we actually going to do some of the
decision-making that's that's involved
well the first thing is that if I just
and I had a target for each station of
course a natural thing would be well can
I just achieve all of that all of those
targets simultaneously answer is
unfortunately not that they actually
aren't enough bikes in the system to do
that it's exam so so what's the right
allocation and so this gives rise to a
math programming model it's a you know
any integer program not surprising as
you looked at those curves those cost
functions are convex this is this is a
optimization problem which does achieve
its optimum it is easily computable and
so we can use this as the basis for the
allocation of bikes but life evolves
through the day and the question is
exactly how much you know we can
accomplish through rebalancing effects
and that and and and I'm going to talk
about five different ways in which we
make decisions to affect the performance
of the system throughout the day so
midrash rebalancing one one mechanism by
which were the rush hour rebalancing
curves which took us by surprise is that
trucks okay make sure we shouldn't have
been so surprised also have problems
moving around at rush hour and so doing
a lot of motorized rebalancing then can
be pretty ineffective not just traffic
access to some I mean how much they can
block a side street
with a truck to unload their their
issues so what they went to in to
significant effect are these trikes so
these are pedicabs where the back part
of this can be used to load up city
bikes and the New York City is
particularly amenable to this kind of
thing because there are pairs of
stations that are relatively close
physically that are diametrically
opposite in terms of the patterns of
behavior so if you look at Grand Central
you know that's at 42nd and whatever and
and and you look at Midtown and let's
say forty fourth and fifth there may be
two Avenue blocks and a couple still
it's a part but but they look just the
opposite so you can have this cyclist
this is outside Grand Central
oh who was exactly cycling between those
two stations oh and it can load up bikes
at one end and and unload them at the
other okay now they had a given limited
resource so it would take him about six
minutes to ride between the the pair of
station he could weave him amongst
traffic and and so so even if traffic
was stopped he managed to go back and
forth so I wouldn't want the job but but
that's that so for this pair oh so these
trikes can hold up to depending on the
design this one could do six there
they're versions that can hold up to
twelve but of course we want there and
the question now is a purely offline
decision-making problem first is you
know what pay you know if I'm thinking
about allocating the the the eight or so
trikes that they have now where should
they allocate them and and we can take
the same and I won't go through the
details but you can imagine things is it
for every pair of stations as you sort
of think about the unraveling of what
happens over the rush-hour how many
trips can you make and
how does that affect the user
dissatisfaction function as it evolves
over the course of that of that
morning's rush hour you you can ascribe
and anticipated improvement in the user
dissatisfaction function at the two end
points associated with pairing that
trike across those things now you could
say that that's probably not the right
thing to do because maybe you want to do
that for a while and you want to do some
other pair but fortunately also the the
pliability of the maintenance staff is
is one thing and giving them simple
directions to just simply go back and
forth between a given pair was was
highly appealing to management so so
what this amounts to when you when you
go through all the the modeling is that
end up you have a way you have a
bipartite graph that you have you know
some stations that are suppliers of
bikes you have some stations that are
that are consumers of bikes and for each
pair that's sufficiently close that it
makes sense to even compute the the
weight of improvement there's a total
improvement over the rush hour that you
can do and we can compute a maximum
weight at home k edge-matching and and
indeed there there there's a display of
one such solutions with diametrically
opposite patterns a few blocks apart
between them good question hey well
because what is it grand central and and
and people use the system in a variety
of ways and I think the biggest use is
what would typically be called last mile
except it's not last mile it's last few
hundred feet that they then if you look
at the distribution of the distance
between pairs of stations in terms of
how often they get used stations that
are very close
get get an enormous fraction I mean
surprisingly large fraction of
of these but is that people who are
actually riding from one station to
another or is it they have an errand
across town and when they come back they
just leave it well I don't think so
because among other things you don't
have an easy locking mechanism while
you're in doing the the air in the cross
town your disincentivize in terms of the
maximum budget that you have on time you
know that there any number of ways that
you would expect the data they're gonna
let go of the bike and try to claim
another one now of course they could be
at a place where there isn't
availability but maybe i'm i don't i
think rebalancing is mostly a function
of of asymmetry of demand and the length
of time is isn't isn't the isn't the we
are it's there it's in place you know
give me 15 25 minutes you know I mean I
even told you was coming was number five
on that list so uh overnight rebalancing
so so that's a box truck it can hold
about 50 bikes there a fleet of about
five of them yes only five of them that
they have they start each night at their
headquarters in in Sunset Park in
Brooklyn and which is in itself part of
the problem in that they spend about an
hour to two hours every day just getting
to where the action is let alone not
rebalancing bikes and and most of the
rebalancing occurs in this 11:00 p.m. to
6:00 a.m.
AM shift and then there are all kinds of
logistical things that because they're
big trucks because this isn't Manhattan
they can't get to certain stations
because they can't get reasonably close
there you name it they're all
of issues but the goal is clear we have
a limited amount of time they have to be
back at the depot at 6:00 a.m. and we
want to maximize the improvement in the
system there and and this can be done
through a series of integer programming
tricks I won't go through them but but
but but nonetheless that is an offline
tool that that this is one of the things
that that's had substantial effect so
how bad is it the next day good we'll
talk about that yeah so so you might say
where is the real-time decision-making I
have to say the things started out
really very primitive the first thing
that we were able to do was we put in
there is a human dispatcher sitting at
headquarters and the first thing is that
this metric allowed us to be able to
sort of put up warning signs of stations
that are out of bikes now in fact and
and for a while I thought this was
private but I just found it on the
public website so I can talk about it
openly is that there's a notion called
never die stations the 10% of all
stations or have a special designation
that are how they come into the service
agreement between motivate and the city
of New York and of course there are
seaport penalties for those never die
stations and therefore more serious
attention paid to those stations so so
there's a dispatch map which sort of
says that for the dispatchers point of
view that that are are we in jeopardy of
paying fines for for being out of bikes
and then the question is where do we
send the trucks to get the bikes from
and and so now at least we have the the
measurement tools to say here at least
the stations that that dispatcher could
say oh let's just go or grab them
from from this station it's relatives
near Novi and that was really the first
it was still a big improvement over what
was done before because there was some
quantitative basis for it but but but
nonetheless that's where things started
what happens now so that there's a
heuristic tool that that we've designed
oh that essentially allows the
dispatcher to have a display that for
each truck that's out on the streets has
a prefix of where that truck should go
given current information that gets
updated over time and again the this
this prefixes is John in a simple you
know greedy ran with randomization
thrown in on top of it heuristic point
of view again what's the goal if I'm
going to route five trucks over the next
two hours how's the best improvement
that I can get over those two hours in
terms of going from the system state in
an untouched way to the system in an
improved way and in fact the heuristic
keeps generating solutions in the
background the dispatcher doesn't get
disturbed by changes too often only when
there's sort of another event in the
system that or some lesser periodicity
this gives you the sense of the look and
feel there's a map piece there's a
there's a this you know for each truck
and then there's sort of an itinerary
displayed and they're warning signals of
what kind on on different stations
but-but-but-but this is so this is now
real-time decision-making done
automatically
exactly guided by the user
dissatisfaction functions oh I forget
who asked this question yeah you see the
sound path so but what can I say about
the effect of overall a bouncing now
this is before that the latest round of
tools went into place our I'm hoping
that maybe life is a little better but
here is a graph that shows so this is
this again because I can tell by the
weather stations is last summer this
summer
sixteen for each of these circles how
read it is says how far that station is
from whether it should be at 6:00 a.m.
the next morning
okay so white would mean we're already
at the level that we want we don't need
any rebalancing deep red means that I
have a lot of rebalancing to be done so
that's where we are at midnight let's
see we are at 6:00 am
and I'm sure all of you think that I
just showed you the same map okay
there's some places where there sublevel
Ripper but I can point that but it's
very limited in terms of its it's a very
and this is this is home this is a
problem so just simply we're not able to
go for the the targeted levels with the
current number of the size of the fleet
of trucks and we need different
techniques in order to do that so one
could ask the question of maybe this
[Music]
yes yes yes so so one question is is the
system designed right and so so all of
the you know there's design we saw this
Brooklyn station which had more than 60
docks and and it seemed to be ludicrous
in and so so one question is that how
much could we be really improving the
system by by a completely different
system design or somewhat different
assistant side
the docks are not welded to the pavement
they actually are just heavy pieces of
machinery sitting on top of the pavement
so a crane can come lift it up onto a
flatbed and move it to some other part
and say they actually come in groups of
three and four so so you so you actually
have the ability to reconfigure the
existing hardware and since you know as
Anton asked that that bikes and docks
are roughly the same order of magnitude
in terms of costs there they're they are
expensive so are we really we're
spending all this energy and on
rebalancing bikes but but but maybe we
should be getting the the system design
right so this gives us rise to a you
know a similar optimization problem for
the daily one and I won't go through the
details but but it's it's not hard to
imagine that we now have a cost that's
it's now a function of for each station
how many empty docks and how many full
docks do I have I have a total
allocation of docks I have a total
allocation of bikes and we can even sort
of think of this as an augmentation
problem that suppose I want to think
about going from my current allocation
to a different allocation and I place
some limit on the number of changes that
I could place because telling the city
that you mean we want you to move all
you know X thousand by docks they aren't
gonna go for that so let's you know what
about a targeted number and of course
through each station there there's some
amount of capacity constraints and
minimum size that that they're willing
to think about
turns out that this is a solvable
problem the underlying objective
function each each term is a has a
property known as multi modularity which
is a kind of diminishing returns
property and as a result we're able to
show that it's a mathematical
optimization problem there's lots of
nice structure in particular if I think
about the space of all allocations of
bikes and docks across the system and I
think about a neighborhood structure on
the set of all those solutions so now
each complete system-wide solution is a
node in your graph and two nodes two
allocations are neighbors if you can get
to one from the other by a simple change
let's say I move a dock from one station
to another I move a bike in a dock to
from one station to another or I just
move a bike or a bit more complicated I
take a bike from one station and a dock
from another and I put them together at
a at a third location so those are all
sort of local changes that I can make
and and and that gives rise to a
neighborhood structure on solutions yes
so so so part of the thing goes back to
the political layer that there are long
complicated negotiations of neighborhood
organization groups within the city that
that I'll have come to an agreement of
we're the stations are going to be
located and what the bounds for how many
but what the upper and lower bounds for
that station could be and that's given
and and yes one could try to go back and
fight but that that's that's that's
that's a level of it that I really don't
wanna go into okay so so this gives a
and and and the the nice mathematical
structure underneath it is that local
optimality equals global optimality here
that if I simply find a solution for
which there isn't an improving move with
respect to these small changes then in
fact that you can prove that that's the
global optimum with respect to the the
coordination problem across all stations
and this actually if you push the same
idea a bit further gives rise that you
can solve the problem by a kind
greedy gradient descends kind of
algorithm where you simply want to start
with your current solution and check to
see if there's an improving move and
make the best improving move that you
can and then and show that that that
then leads to the optimal solution and
in fact you can therefore show that if
you're going to move it most ke docks
that this can give rise to the best
solution achievable where you're only
allowing yourself to move in most chaos
there's an interesting sort of
theoretical computer science subtlety
that what's the size of the input here
and you sort of think about you know a
solution that's moving one bike at a
time that you're ending up with
something that's proportional to the
number of bikes and docks in the system
but as theoretical computer scientists
we're trained that if I think about
specifying the input to the problem then
if I want to say how many bikes there
are then I only need log the number of
bikes bits to specify that input rather
than that so in some sense this is not a
polynomial number of iterations and one
could imagine analogous versions of this
problem where the commodities are
digital and that you could be the first
easy solution is say that my bike fleet
is given to me in unary I count one bike
two bikes three bikes for bikes and and
and and therefore it's okay but actually
one can prove that that there's an
improved version of the algorithm where
just in terms of the number of Oracle
calls to the costume to the user to
satisfaction functions you can reduce
the dependence to be logarithmic on the
number of bikes and docks in the system
okay
I forget who asked this question I'm Tom
I asked you know why don't I just not do
anything so here's a model that I could
think about not doing anything I'll
think of it as sort of the long turn
average just to imagine that I'm running
the the the stochastic model of where
things are until I reach a steady state
okay
and now suppose I'm thinking about
optimizing what the system should get
designed for in those terms rather than
in terms of the fact that I'm sort of
thinking about with the Harry Potter
magic wand every night I'm gonna get to
my perfect state the next by the next
morning what's the nicest thing that
could happen to me from an allocation
point of view well it sort of jit happen
is that optimizing with respect to this
function is not so different in terms of
the kind of system that I want to
configure is not so different than if I
actually think about what I'm doing in
terms of the optimal rebalancing and
indeed well I guess I'm not running out
of time so we did an experimental design
based on New York data that allows us to
do a series of of comparisons let's take
one month's worth of data let's optimize
the system with respect to the one-day
optimum and what's the right system of
Docs and lenlen we can evaluate that
dock allocation with both respect to
what happens with the long-term average
and there and and also try to understand
the effect of how many docs would it
take to get better performance so I've
confused the design a little bit because
I'm now trying to do two things at once
that I'm first trying to get some
understanding of what kind of effect
would moving Docs have on overall system
performance and then the question of how
might I measure that effect both in
terms of the protocol where I'm thinking
about rebalancing perfectly overnight
versus I'm thinking about not doing any
rebalancing o at all
you run that process forward and invite
deads to a station without a dog oh so
we make it disappear from the system
basically simulations allow us to do
magical things right good so so so this
is the the first step in in this
experiment so now if I think about the
number of docs that I'm allowing to move
how many docs do do I want to move in
total and how much improvement can I get
overall so here the sort of punchlines
so this is off of June 2015 data that we
end up with twelve hundred fewer out of
stock events which is about thirty
percent of the original by redesigning
the system completely the number of
Doc's needed to be moved is with sixteen
hundred which is at that point about 17
percent of the total number of Doc's but
but on the other hand they're sort of
this is a phenomenon of diminishing
returns and so if I only move five
hundred dogs so two-and-a-half percent
of the overall system
I get to a level of improvement of
objective that's comparable to what
citibike thinks they gain by all of
their motorized rebalancing efforts
daytime over night whatsoever so that
this one-time event can can accomplish
the same order of magnitude then that
that all of the and of course the two
things are not orthogonal we can get
sort of the improvements from from both
yes yes so this is all within the range
of there now in fact this happened I
mean we didn't get 500 Docs moot we got
a small number of Docs moved but but of
it in fact they they have been moving
Docs so as to improve the overall design
of the system according to the the the
models that we've been running yeah
politics I mean they're they're also
bigger issues that which we'll talk
about coming up that that they come into
play is sort of why they still for that
might not be the right issues to be
focusing on at this moment in time yeah
the rebalancing capacity in terms of you
know five slots in all trucks used
I'm I I mean again I'm now going back
over that something of the order of a
couple thousand bikes could get touched
over the course of a day Oh at any given
moment in time
oh so total capacity is like four
hundred across the entire fleet there
may be three or four sprinters and five
box trucks so so yeah and then this when
you move this treadmill your number of
this last year cuz you wind up
so so so now if we're measuring what the
level of improvements looks like across
other months of traffic we still get
improvements so so the fact that we made
the design decision once and and there
and also the difference between the C
and the C pie or this is the long term
average where I'm not doing any
rebalancing which is probably a fair
thirty thousand v you again the same I
mean the the the the fine-tuning of
exactly what these functions look like
is about the same but the the by and
large the same improvements happen so
the the meta messages please move these
Knox so one other way in which and this
this happened it about the same time is
that
when when this fizz system was first set
up it was well I mean is immediately
obvious that there was this tremendous
inflow into the financial district there
was a great amount of focus on this
partly because that's where their
investors were all working and and and
and that they were it was painfully
visible that the docks were unavailable
instantly and and one thing that no one
asked today but always somebody asked is
but it isn't the same thing to be
missing a bike is to be missing a dock
because I have to return the bike so so
so there are real issues here
so one thing they did is they planted a
box truck within the financial district
at 6 a.m. so that when the first round
the bikes filled up one dock they
unloaded that dock onto the truck and
then they drove it away but then they
had to drive that truck back at 3 p.m.
so it's to fill the not a good idea so
they came up with this idea of a Corral
which basically said that we were
granted the right to use this real
estate as a result of running this
program we're going to use it more
effectively so that there's enough space
between a pair of physical docks that
you can stack a few extra bikes
literally on top of each other there and
then lock them down so so that there
would be someone who would maintain this
and maintain that it was locked and you
could more or less quadruple the
capacity of a station and actually still
by keeping a few docks sort of normal
that that the sort of transient day
middle of the day usage could still be
left unencumbered but what you do be
able to get get much greater usage out
of the station as well human human does
that yes yes so so then there's a
question of how many humans they were
willing to allocate to do this and how
do you space this and again we could
build models it gives rise to a nice
facility location problem and and and
indeed that's what determines how they
staff and where they put them in indeed
I think these are still to the state
where those those Corral's are located
ok now a lot of this is driven and a lot
of the issues and how operation by city
bikes pricing scheme which is just
completely stupid I mean the scheme is
just set up to fail and this is true
across all of I mean Northam and this is
what motivate ago she ated with with
with the city of New York but but but
any number of of these they're several
North American firms that have come into
agreements with with variety of urban
centers and they all have more or less
the same structure you can buy a one-day
pass or a three-day pass for small
amount of money or you can buy an annual
subscription which is an all-you-can-eat
kind of thing and it just gives you
unlimited access to the system in New
York if you look at how different users
you saying
the key users get a sweet deal
those traders in the East Village who go
to the financial district I mean they
use it hon well more than a hundred of
time there isn't good public
transportation between their two end
points they probably were taking taxis
or maybe they had switched to uber that
at that point but they're paying you
know under a buck a ride really under
half a buck a ride typically and and and
this in itself is sort of a
destabilizing fact and just if you know
know balance you talked about this you
know it's charging for what it really
would be worth to people would have
changed I mean you would give you more
give them much more resources to be able
to do the kind of rebalancing but it
very much inspired by biology's work we
proposed to city bike that we implement
an incentive scheme the and part of the
thing comes into and this also comes to
the reservation question is that the way
the contract works for between motivate
in the city of New York is they are
guaranteed guaranteeing providing this
kind of subscription plan and this with
someone asked a question of why not just
differential pricing incentives they can
ask ad without violating the contract at
all vacant it's just a an added bonus on
top thing it doesn't change the pricing
scheme but it's a way of implementing
differential pricing
without having to you know get the
city's okay and the city you know they
there are regular conversations of the
d-o-t so they knew was coming it's a
surprise but it was an interesting layer
against collections that are expected
and promised to be certain level this is
recorded an incentive portion now
because then I would be running on the
bond terms I say so this is interesting
you know the private companies doing the
collection of money the city's very
happy to let go inside yeah yes
interesting I mean it could be just that
the deity didn't think hard enough about
whether you know what they really should
they're basically they allowed it to go
forward and life was good and and we
started yeah and from going through this
to differential pricing then that seemed
to be you up like isn't that kind of
like a thing in between
just just non differential pricing to
try it first because I this is an
enormous discount for anything really
often so just have a so-so but the point
is that I I'm not gonna give a discount
for writing often I'm gonna give a
discount for making rides that we know
are good systems or is giving a discount
for writing often because it's a day
pass right like I mean they're not even
a much simpler thing to try in the
middle which is just a fixed price per
ride yeah but that would require the
d-o-t buying into it and
and I mean there are various fictions
that the city likes to believe which is
that this is about a gala tere and urban
transit in spite of the fact it's
painfully obvious of if you look at the
demographics of the locations where the
stations are there are noticeable
differences depending on what
neighborhood and what the demographic
characteristics of those neighbors are
so there are a lot of falsehoods that
are sort of built into you know we're
pretending that things are not as as
easy as they are and then anyway so so
there now is this is off of the city
bike webpage a program called bike
angels which is exactly an incentive
system the the first cut at this we did
something really just to give you a
sense of the power of incentives in a
small anecdotal way is that there are a
pair of stations exactly like this
proposing the middle one which were
relatively close one was stressed one
wasn't in the usual commute traffic flow
away we targeted all of the users who
had used either of the two stations in
the last some period of time I forget
what and we sent split them into two
random samples we split sent half of
them just in an email saying you might
consider using this other station
because it more readily has more bikes
in the morning and the other we sends
along with it and if you do you'll get
entered into a lottery for a prize
amazing difference in terms of how
people actually responded and this was
our hook I mean we we sort of hoped that
this was the case that that motivate
would be willing to play along I mean we
had read Balaji's papers we knew that
this was going to happen so so that that
that that the a little bit of a little
nudge goes a long way
so so what's the nature of the system
currently is that every station is
either left neutral or left incentivized
for a pickup or incentivized for a
drop-off in fact there could be a
multi-point drop-off being sort of it
could be really highly incentivized for
a pickup it's it's purely additive
between the the two end points so that
you can get a bonus at one and be
neutral at the other end and and you can
keep doing it over the course of a rush
hour okay so so so this is the system
it's gamified in you know how many
points you get there's a leaderboard in
terms of the this month of how many
points you've actually accrued there
there are some featured bike angels who
you know say cute things like I like to
do a bike angels workout where L both
bike North and Central Park to an empty
station then run back down the park and
repeat a few times anyway so so said
this is real and this is its impact so
so in version one which was done with a
10% of all users were invited to
participate in the pilot program 1%
actually signed up and then there was
simply a static map we didn't you know
we didn't touch the map over the course
of you know every morning rush hour
looked exactly the same every afternoon
rush hour looked exactly the same not
the right thing to do we knew it wasn't
the right thing to do but it's what we
could admit we knew is like we at least
we kept our fingers crossed that nothing
too bad would happen and each of these
dots is and is a ride that one of those
pilot users took and what you're seeing
is that the the time of the ride across
the morning rush hour and notice that
that we were doing in sensitization of a
huge time window from from 6 6 a.m. to
noon we're you know it's not clear and
you see a lot of
means that that you know you shouldn't
have done it red means it was good and
this was sort of retrospectively in
terms of that but but the message is
overwhelmingly we got people to do more
good rides now then there's the question
of and to some extent you can do based
on people's behavior as they in the
first two weeks they join of what they
did in the previous two weeks were there
and so you can do all the usual kinds of
testing to get a sense of what the
impact is the terms of service here how
do you how do you write the original
agreement to say you may not be asked to
participate in incentive programs that
other people are asked if there's this
differential if it's not so we actually
so actually some number of people
participated who weren't asked and that
was all just fine so this was this was
just because they didn't want to I mean
they were tentative about how they were
to be rolled out of the city more whitey
this is how you do these things that is
in fact all the Terms of Service not
written but you may be invited
it's experimental environment
participate in some programs of may
eventually succeed okay so my takeaway
is that that's a term and clause to
watch out for yeah yeah I mean there's a
lot of people get invited I mean often
these things that yeah they even really
people don't read terminal service that
much and if someone complains and so
this was summer of 16 summer 17 we
started doing smarter all the things so
each station under the right set of
conditions it's easy to prove that for
each rush hour
there should be one continuous interval
that you're incentivizing that and you
can make a determination either you do
it in a static way based on the six am
level as to what the interval that gets
incentivized for that stations day or
you can simply do it as a real-time
every 30 minutes am I willing to shut
the incentivization down start it up or
store in the end start it I said it
often and you know there are a number of
experiments in this the analogous
pictures are getting much better because
you are sooner you you aren't doing
things where you already know it's
stupid and in general it's not
surprising that I mean you're living a
little bit on a nice edge for one of
these really busy
stations that as you get to the middle
of the day the polarity is going to
switch in terms of what that station
should be like and if the last thing you
want to do is be stocking yourself
encouraging an extra bike which are
going to be ruing that there's actually
there come come the afternoon so so so
there is this delicacy of exactly where
it's okay to keep things going as you
get towards the end of that rush hour
here's an odd real-time decision that we
only recently started paying we were
asked to come up with something that
works and actually we don't have good
things to say so you open your app and
you're at home and you you decide you
want to decide should I go to this
station to pick up a bike
one thing you'd sort of like is some
warning signal hey this station is at
risk now the regular user has a way of
knowing it's at risk it's empty or it's
near empty but but after all we should
be able to better write that so one
natural thing and it's I'm sure half of
you have already thought about in the
ten seconds since I said it is that if
you think about the net flow rate that
occurs at that station and just think of
that as a fluid model that rather than
thinking about it in the stochastic
process on cents just think about it
sort of draining at whatever filling in
that that that fractional rate you know
doesn't reach some threshold of your
emptiness or near fullness there it's
not clear that the real data this is
helping so much and and this
want to pose a sort of philosophical
question of that this is a first-order
method right you're really just thinking
of the net flow as is the the big thing
and that meant flow is the difference of
two two quantities the the renting rate
and the the return rate and and if you
sort of think of it sort of resulting
net flow being Delta it might have
arisen is sort of a big plus Delta minus
big or it might have arise for a little
plus Delta a minus little now usually
from a stochastic point of view you sort
of think about well big has both sort of
a you know a centrality and a
possibility of more extreme events kind
of phenomenon there's also the fact that
if you are at a the big your you're at a
more active station and you know you
maybe you could wrestle that that
bikeway firm those users anyway and so
it's not in clear either from a
theoretical point of view or that how
you want to think about what the role of
the variance though I'm not really don't
mean variance but some sort of psycho
second-order term should be and I think
this is it mean this just sort of is as
a toy simple question I this is
something that should have a nice clean
solution that really does well on data
and I don't know how to do it so few
more questions in the system this
stockless in based bike so biology
already asked earlier you know as I
talked about the service level
agreements and that the providers are
committed to the system they have but
they can add other you know possible
structures on top of it as long as they
don't take away the others so they you
know could they have a platinum user
charge that user four times as much but
allow that user to make reservations now
there are political optics and they're
still running but but again how you
think about all of the pricing questions
and all of the operations questions
becomes much more challenging and you
want to be able for you advise an entity
this you you want to have a sense of the
implications and have the right models
and I think these are all great
questions to think about there's some
work out there but but but exactly how
you know it opens up the field that you
can do all kinds of different pricing
mechanisms as long as you're dealing
with those platinum users and and and I
think this is really a nice suite of
questions that they're for mass transit
pretty much that's like next slide yeah
okay but Oh fo this polity just
mentioned the new new thing Oh Doc's are
passe maybe maybe Doc's are passe so all
the North American systems are built
around this notions of stations with
Docs and and and people rented one of
the other but two startups in China both
by now unicorns billion dollar
valuations o fo and mobike o our running
systems where you can pick up any bike
anywhere open your app see where their
bikes it'll recommend the few to you
it'll in sent a memo bike has an
incentive system so it'll even say you
get a little red envelope on some which
is bigger red envelope it's even more
important for you to to pick up that
bike and and then return it you know
stop riding it where you want hopefully
not in the middle of the road and all
kinds of other things but but this you
know changes the playing field
completely it's a little bit of warning
so the brake I mean it becomes a very
heavy paperweight unless you've unlocked
it on your weight so it basically it
locks to itself
the app allows you to release the
braking mechanism and therefore then you
can start riding it
however if you google bike graveyard
these are the pictures that you see it
is a big public menace at this point in
China in terms of how the systems are
getting abused they're still getting
used and there are more I mean as
someone who visited Beijing first 20 but
somewhere between 15 20 years ago and
you know is it okay the city of
tremendous bicycle traffic it's still a
city of bicycle traffic but there are
more bike share bikes on the road then
there are privately held bikes on the
road in Beijing so just complete shift
in terms of how the systems get run but
there's tremendous amount of work now to
be done I mean exactly that we mean we
have a good understanding of the kinds
of models that how traffic flows and
they're starting of course to be lots of
papers being written about what how to
how to model traffic but I don't think
it's there how do we think about doing
incentives and how we think about
pricing these kinds of rides so is to to
make these in and really the question is
how much is the concept of having
centralized parking absolutely
imperative for maintaining the
operations of these systems maybe then
the natural thing and the the stable
point is to derive an incentive system
that show that drives an overwhelming
fraction of the traffic to be between
centralized stations but then still
allows where people are willing to pay
more and being you know the therefore
able to park sort of in a more dispersed
manner but what's the right way in which
this system because they're clearly
operational questions that the
operational needs in how a system like
this gets run effectively and it also
comes into play when when when bike
sharing first started being concerned
can
by operations people it almost was
called the soccer problem because the
first visible bike sharing program was
in Paris and soccer was always empty at
the end of the day because it was uphill
and from everywhere else and so everyone
wrote downhill New York where I have to
admit most of my experiences is
especially over the weird the large
piece of the footprint that the city
bike currently operates is is more or
less topography free it's not it's not
completely flat but it's not San
Francisco where again we're gonna you
know that they're just rolling out on
the tenfold expansion of go bike in and
and exactly how this is going to be
managed and it'll be interesting to see
the data so it's you know what is the
effect of topography and and and and
DOCSIS stock based systems versus
stockless ones and and you know how we
should evaluate the topography is again
I think a big big challenge and that's
all I want to say so happy to take
questions system have data on the users
so if 80 or 90 percent of people that
are pretty regular right at least on
weekdays then can you design the
augmentation system where in the morning
the afters tell you you should go to
station a to pick up that choice they
should be and then your system can then
you can have incentive so that if I
could see this is where the the pricing
structure is broken because I mean the
mean there's this very slow feedback
loop for an annual subscription if if
they knew they were losing the user by
not serving them that well they would
work better at serving the individual
user better and and this is a challenge
I mean so it's exactly sort of says that
a lot of the the analytic smarts to the
system could be really pushed if they
went to this two-tier system because
then they'd be incentivized to try to
figure out how to deliver a higher
quality
service in their range in which this
individual level data could be used is
all condemning the censoring kind of
thing what we do is is really primitive
but if I mean I mean it's pretty
frightening if you look at you know a
user over you know two months you know a
lot about that person's life and and and
what you can infer in terms of whether
they might be willing to shift one
station over and and all kinds of things
would be more effective if you went sort
of in the Delta that an individual user
level you can put in incentives of where
they pick up the bike already return the
bike is that being discussed stuff yes
but but the point is they they think
it's hopeless that they'll get control
back of I mean unless they completely
saw I mean so that the the agreement
with the city requires that they be
public about the Jason feed about you
know what the status is and that means
that they're going to be third-party
providers and they've lost the users for
so they have to figure out ways that
users are incentivized to use the app so
then which the bike angels is doing so
so but but but but but for them the
bigger threat is stockless and they're
the Dhokla see is I mean the essence the
app is the unlocking business and
they're already I mean I know there are
negotiations going on for for having
some sort of bimodal system within New
York and I'm sure in many of their
markets because I mean mobike is I mean
it has it has certainly announced its
intentions to open in DC I don't know if
it actually has started in DC so so now
they have to get rights from the city
and there are those kinds of fights that
are coming but but but yeah I mean there
certainly are discussions all your
analysis if I understand correctly is
based on stock levels of bikes and dogs
you also have information on the routes
that bikes take you don't know so they
don't know you know by now there are not
yeah
there might be it might be an urban myth
that the original fleet at least in in
New York City had GPS on them
the original fleet was decision I mean
that you can track their actual oh okay
but you know it went from this station
to that stage yes yes so all I wanted is
that information of any use as far as I
can tell you never actually made use of
it in any of the analysis you showed us
doesn't it tell you something more than
that would be so it comes into the sort
of back-end simulation models for what
so it also comes in the other thing that
it comes into play and I've just
completely put this under the rug is
that a lot of the models have gone to
versions that are not just station
centric but cluster of station centric
so that we think about availability
we're thinking about it for a station
and it's its neighbors rather than for
the individual station and therefore
knowing exactly you know the the routing
comes into play a bit but I there still
isn't a lot of signal in terms of the at
least that we know how to use
you know we had to sort of dollar that
person for you know a week number of
Sanford's that's four thousand dollars
roughly importantly some people here
five dollars somebody actually or
something really nice like this
surprisingly if you actually give ball
tickets which point is so much more
people values are a lot more like it was
proportionately there's only so many of
them and they exceeded the monetary
value it's only four dollars a ticket
those people activated some Saturn or
fifty dollars yeah so we got when we had
drives
retroland just the Rose Bowl tickets why
they notice for 17% in creationists
let's take the bigger now order of ten
tickets okay there's no way 750 dollars
could of gotten 75 times 10 for a
goddess
somebody person increase who wasn't you
not this one someone from city but
unless you see
suggesting universe the teams it's for
giving dollars back incentives if you
are posted I mean most of the I mean
actually at this point a significant
fraction and I don't know how big it is
at this point of the prizes awarded for
the incentives which are again lottery
base mothers are actually one week free
extensions to their membership which of
course you know this is exactly the best
thing possible because you're keeping
the people who are willing to do the the
against the main flow rides engaged in
the system you want that I mean you you
you are happy to pay them to keep
writing so-so but I agree that's not the
same thing as the occasional thing that
would drive membership and that's that
support to consider these tickets like
yeah that's a good point
do you have a sense of how many trips
shorter than one mind I've made my bike
versus walking versus versus simple
answers no no I mean it's a good
question
I mean the uber I guess no we only have
pin the only mayor public about is the
pickup data I guess taxi we could but
actually that's probably bad data
because how many times of that have any
of us try to use a taxi and tell them we
were only going there and they said no
thank you I I mean I think anecdotally I
mean it's it's extremely likely that
those that are short are taking away
from from from walking more than
anything else the seasonal fluctuation
is very large it's not as large as you
think then so for example I was just
looking last month which wasn't a
particularly snowy December but it was
still pretty cold there was one a real
cold snap the typical average uses was
around 15,000 trips a day as opposed to
70 75,000 at the peak of September so
it's a three to four as a factor as long
as there aren't extreme weather people
still have to get from A to B and if
they're if they have some other mode to
do it in the winter it aren't used this
is not an actual necessity you know you
can find an alternative mode if you
if you need to so maybe we should sing
David and enjoy I guess we have we back